wird der astronomie bei einer weiteren
passage die erde treffen und tod und
verwüstung anrichten ein forschungsteam
der nasa hat neue daten ausgewertet und
das anschlagsrisiko neu berechnet
demnach ist ein einschlag
wahrscheinlicher als gedacht dass es
beunruhigend aber es gibt auch
beruhigendes zu berichten und leider
wiederum auch beunruhigen dass klick zum
science and future gegen zwei mal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktive die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen fest steht dass der
astro unserem heimatplaneten der erde im
jahr 2035 näher kommen wird als die
mondumlaufbahn fachleute weltweit gehen
zwar nicht davon aus dass der 500 meter
brocken zu diesem zeitpunkt mit der erde
kollidieren wird doch das
anschlagsrisiko könnte sich durch diesen
nahen vorbeiflug erhöhen durch den
schwerkraft einfluss der erde könnte
sich die bahn von benny so verändern
dass wir uns bei einem weiteren
vorbeiflug näher kommt als uns lieb ist
hier steht sogar die frage im raum ob er
bei einer weiteren passage sogar mit
voller wucht die erde treffen wird und
das hätte verheerende folgen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit haben wenn du deswegen ganz
genau im visier und jetzt gibt es neue
berechnungen ein nasa forschungsteam hat
aktuelle daten ausgewertet und
analysiert wie hoch die gefahr wirklich
ist das menü in der nahen zukunft auf
die erde trifft genau darum geht es
jetzt bei pixum sei zum future das leben
auf der erde ist bedroht durch
asteroiden und das pausenlos denn viel
häufiger als manch einer von uns denken
mag trinkt ein asteroid in die
atmosphäre ein explodiert oder schlägt
sogar ein pro monat sind es etwa 150
neue hast du ihnen die in der nähe
unseres heimatplaneten aufgespürt werden
in der sogenannten near earth objects
liste sind mittlerweile etwa 20.000
objekte aufgelistet doch klar ist auch
dass vor allem kleinere asteroiden
bisher noch im verborgenen blieben und
wie sie noch gar nicht auf dem schirm
haben und auch von ihnen gehen hohe
risiken aus die das leben auf der erde
ernsthaft bedroht nicht nur der aufprall
selbst sondern auch dessen folgen sind
nicht ohne erdbeben oder teilweise noch
schlimmer gigantische tsunami fachleute
weltweit haben besonders einen
asteroiden im blick denn wir haben schon
öfter bei pixum future über diesen 500
meter brocken berichtet eingestuft wird
der 60 millionen tonnen schwere panel
als potenziell gefährlich seine
umlaufbahn dauert 1,2 jahre und so
kreutz ja immer mal wieder die
umlaufbahn der erde um die sonne alle
paar jahre kommt er uns sogar ziemlich
nahe viereinhalb milliarden jahre alt
ist er und besonders kohlenstoff reich
mit hilfe der nasa-mission osiris rex
willmann bände genauer kennenlernen eine
sonde kartiert den us zu ihnen dabei
genau in den proben von seiner
oberfläche diese kommen wahrscheinlich
in zwei jahren 2023 auf der erde an und
werden dann hoffentlich einige
geheimnisse über den asteroiden
offenbaren doch bereits jetzt steht fest
beispielsweise in den jahren 2000 135
und 2167 könnte wenn du der erde
tatsächlich gefährlich nahe kommen
natürlich haben wissenschaftler der nasa
am wissenschaftlerin schon das worst
case szenario berechnet beim aufprall
wurde er demnach eine energie von
80.000 atombomben freisetzen keine frage
das hätte unvorstellbare schlimme folgen
für das leben auf der erde kein wunder
also dass mit hochdruck an möglichen
abwehrmaßnahmen gearbeitet wird so
beispielsweise die nasa behörde
planetary die fans team ihr plan heißt
hemmer und das steht für high velocity
estoril tägigen mission for emergency
response wege ein neun meter langes und
knapp neun tonnen schwere raumschiff das
mit einer delta 4 heavy in den weltraum
gebracht werden soll es könnte als eine
art rammbock dienen beispielsweise für
benni denn ein oder mehrere kleine
schupp sagt könnten den asteroiden zu
einer kursänderung bringen das problem
nicht einmal das raumschiff dafür ist
geplant und je mehr zeit vergeht umso
schwieriger gestaltet sich dieser plan
dennoch fachleute sind sich darüber
einig dass dieser sogenannte kinetics
apac tor die einzige realistische
möglichkeit wäre die bahn eines
asteroiden zu verändern auch china
beteiligt sich daran die welt zu retten
und hat erst vor kurzem eine neue
technik vorgeschlagen mit der killer
asteroiden auf kollisionskurs mit der
erde abgewehrt werden könnten demnach
wären 23 raketen des typs langer marsch
5 notwendig um einen potentiellen killer
asteroiden wie benny von seinem
reaktions kurs abzubringen das ist das
spannende ergebnis einer simulation des
china national space science centers
doch wie groß ist das anschlagsrisiko
wirklich genau dieser frage ist ein nasa
forschungsteam um den wissenschaftler
davide von nokia nachgegangen als basis
dienten die aktuellen daten die die
osiris rex raumsonde in den vergangenen
zwei jahren rund um ben gesammelt hat
eine gute gelegenheit wie die nasa
forscherin kelly fast sagt die us vision
hat uns eine außerordentliche chance
geboten genauer vorherzusagen wo bendel
sein wird wenn er der erde in mehr als
einem jahrhundert nahe kommen in der
aktuellen studie wird noch einmal
deutlich dass das jahr 2035 entscheidend
sein wird ob und wie das leben auf der
erde weiter gehen wird denn genau dann
wird benni der erde sehr nahe kommt
wobei kein wirkliches anschlagsrisiko
besteht doch die nahe passage vom menü
sorgt dafür dass die schwerkraft der
erde auswirkungen auf seine flugbahn
haben könnte und genau das könnte dann
wiederum das anschlagsrisiko bei einer
weiteren späteren passage erheblich
erhöhen entscheidend hierfür ist laut
des forschungsteams ob im jahr 2009 135
also 114 jahren durch eines der
sogenannten schlüssellöcher fliegen wird
die fachleute meinen damit positionen im
erdnahen raum in denen die schwerkraft
menü auf kollisionskurs mit der erde
lenken könnte insgesamt geht man von 26
kritischen schlüssel löchern aus wenn es
um benno geht das nasa forschungsteam
hat nun herausgefunden dass der killer
us cent davon sehr wahrscheinlich 24
verfehlen wird heißt aber auch zeit zum
durchatmen bleibt nicht ein einschlag
bis zum jahr 2003 100 kann somit also
nicht ganz sicher ausgeschlossen werden
laut der aktuellen studie liegt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür das panel bis
zum jahr 2003 100 meter erde kollidieren
wird bei 1 zu
1750 frühere berechnungen waren von
einer wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu 2700
für einen einschlag bis zum jahr 2200
ausgegangen die chancen haben sich also
deutlich erhöht am wahrscheinlichsten
ist es demnach zudem dass der asteroid
die erde am 24 september 2001 82 treffen
wird wenn es denn zu einer kollision
kommt doch dieser wert kann sich auch
noch verändern wie die fachleute sagen
in 16 jahren nämlich im jahr 2037 wird
wenn du wieder einmal relativ nah an der
erde vorbeifliegen dann wollen die
astrophysikerin und astrophysiker noch
einmal mit der hilfe von teleskopen
seine bahn daten aktualisieren zwei
mögliche einflussfaktoren hatte das nasa
forschungsteam bei der aktuellen analyse
genauer unter die lupe genommen zum
einen ist der sogenannte jarkowski
effekt wichtig für eine risikoanalyse
geht es um die sonneneinstrahlung die
die seiten des asteroiden
unterschiedlich stark aufheizt es
entsteht an strahlungsdruck der einen
asteroiden wie menü nach innen oder
außen ablenken kann demnach können die
flugbahnen von asteroiden also durch die
einstrahlung der sonne verändert werden
und das kann man sich so vorstellen die
sonneneinstrahlung kann unter bestimmten
umständen dazu führen dass der aston
gleichmäßig erwärmt wird diese wärme
energie kann dann asymmetrisch wieder
abgestrahlt werden und genau das hat
einen einfluss auf die flugbahn das so
ist kann in geringem ausmaß in eine
bestimmte richtung gelenkt werden erst
vor kurzem haben wir ja bei pixum satz
in future über diesen effekt beim killer
asteroiden apophis berichtet auch hier
hat der ja kowski effekt einfluss er
sorgt tatsächlich dafür dass apophis
jedes jahr um etwa 170 meter von seiner
bislang vorhergesagten umlaufbahn
abweicht auch wenn das erst einmal nach
wenig klingt langfristig gesehen ist das
eine ganze menge die wärme ja da hast du
ihn ausstrahlt verleiht dem also noch
einen extra schub um also mehr über den
jakob ski effekt und seine auswirkungen
herauszufinden untersucht die nase eben
nun auch benny sehr genau denn vor allem
wenn es um die sogenannten
schlüssellöcher geht kann die s-bahn
bestimmt seien nun haben die nasa
forschenden denen ja kowski effekt bei
benno genauer analysiert der effekt auf
brände entspricht etwa der masse von
drei weintrauben das ist unglaublich
wenig aber signifikant wenn es um das
anschlagsrisiko einige jahrzehnte bis
jahrhunderte in der zukunft geht denn
bei hohen geschwindigkeiten und über
lange strecken können minimale kräfte
große auswirkungen haben osiris rex von
der nasa soll zudem aber auch zeigen wie
genau das modell zur berechnung des jack
auf ski effects wirklich ist im besten
fall kann es so verfeinert werden dass
die flugbahn von asteroiden zukunft noch
viel genauer vorhergesagt werden können
das könnte dann natürlich auch bei den
berechnungen zu abruf ist zum einsatz
kommen bei ihrer risikoanalyse zu band
hatte das nasa forschungsteam einen
weiteren faktor genauer unter die lupe
vorgenommen und zwar die osiris rex
mission selbst denn er hatte die
raumsonde eine gaskrise genutzt um die
oberfläche von benny aufzuwühlen und
dann proben zu entnehmen hat er das etwa
auswirkungen auf die flugbahn hier
konnte das forschungsteam entwarnung
geben zitat die kraft die bei diesem
ereignis auf bendel ausgeübt wurde war
selbst im vergleich zu den anderen
schwachen einflussfaktoren winzig denn
im gegensatz zur sonne die dauerhaft
eine geringe kraft auf den asteroiden
ausübt war das eine geringe kraft die
zudem auch nur sehr kurz gewirkt hat die
aktuelle studie verdeutlicht also wieder
das asteroiden eine gefahr für das leben
auf der erde sind zwar konnte das
zukünftige anschlagsrisiko von benny
näher eingegrenzt werden doch erst
weitere vorbeiflüge können offenbar wie
bedrohlich nah uns wenn ihr wirklich
kommen wird und was wir nicht vergessen
dürfen statistisch gesehen ist irgendein
astrid bereits auf kollisionskurs mit
der erde vielleicht haben wir ihn noch
nicht entdeckt aber wenn wir ihn
gefunden haben dann müssen wir schnell
handeln deshalb zählt inzwischen quasi
jede sekunde um eine mission startbereit
zu machen die einen asteroiden
zuverlässig von seinem kollisionskurs
ablenken kann beim killer asteroiden
apophis wurde ja auch die flugbahn
falsch berechnet was tut sich da
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
diesen kanal hier klicken oder mit dem
abo button unter jedem video kostet
nichts und macht schlauch bis dann
bleibt dran